[Music]
isn't
sasuke okay with that out of the way
quick question for you
what exactly happened between this scene
here at the beginning of the story
and this scene here at the end of the
anime's first season
the two mirror each other pretty closely
both times the first year students are
sent to investigate a seemingly average
case without the support
of other due to sorceress both times
nobura gets abducted and both times it
turns out that the curse they're facing
was actually a special grade that
consumed one of sukuna's fingers
and yet everything is different this
time
our protagonists voluntarily enter the
curse's domain
instead of suddenly being trapped in it
in the second scene it's not for shiguro
but itadori that goes after nobura while
megumi actually stays behind to fight
both of them have clearly grown stronger
and together they take out two of the
special grades in a very
impressive manner
now these two missions are clearly set
up to show the growth of our
protagonists
while itadori has clearly grown in power
and mentality
the most drastic character development
is fushigoros who doesn't run away like
last time but
stands his ground and ultimately defeats
the previously unbeatable special grade
by letting his own power sloughs
all with a manic grin on his face so
what's happened here who is fushigoro
megomi why does his role as the typical
rival
slash deuteragonist to itadori works so
much better than in many other stories
and why is he so important to both
sukuna and gojo
this is the story of fushigoro megumi
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
on the surface fushigoro megomi seems to
be your typical
rival character while itadori appears to
have a light mood
is extremely extroverted and runs mostly
on emotions and instinct
megumi seems to be the classic contrast
to that
[Music]
with spiky dark hair and a quiet and
calculating personality
he seems to be the classic trope of the
cool but brooding rival
the introversion to itadore's
extraversion the dark to itadore's light
fushigoro isn't sasuke because just as
itadori subverts
trope after trope of your typical shonen
protagonist
fushigoro's character unlike sasuke or
bakugo
actually comes a lot closer to some of
togashi's characters
like kurapika or hire from yuyu hakusho
but as always akutami has taken a number
of successful character tropes
merged them and made a character that is
much more complex and intriguing than
the sum of its parts
now as you might have already realized
without some dude analyzing anime on the
internet telling you so
the central theme of hoshigoro's
character is the shadow
[Music]
as we will discuss in a second this goes
both for his jiu-jitsu abilities
as well as for his personality and
character arc megumi is a user of the 10
shadow technique
a rare ability inherited from the
powerful zain family allowing him to
control up to 10
shikigami which are basically cursed
spirits that can be tamed and used by a
sorcerer
now the real feat of this technique is
not the ability to control these
shikigami by themselves but the fact
that megumi is able to manipulate
shadows as a medium
summoning his creatures directly from
shadows and being able to store
objects or even himself within them we
actually see him discover this feature
in real time in this scene here
and this is actually not the only time
that it's sukuna who inspires him to get
stronger
i think it's clear that sukuna is not
interested in megumi for his shikigami
but for the powers of his shadows
and so i'm pretty sure that we'll see
him discover new features and
applications of this ability in the near
future as well
on top of this megumi actually likes to
get his hands dirty
engaging in close combat together with
his shikigami
this actually gets him further respect
with sukuna as these sorts of powers are
usually used at range in the g2 world
with the user at a safe distance from
the battlefields
now although fushigoro's juju technique
allows him to control shadows
in terms of his character a deeper
darkness within
actually controls him
[Music]
when we first meet fushigoro just like
itadori he has a weird tendency for
self-sacrifice
for instance we know that fushigoro has
a trump card up his sleeve that was a
threat
even to sokuna at the cost of
foshiguro's own life
and yet the number of times we see him
almost using this last resort in the
first season of the anime alone
is absolutely ridiculous
pretty much every single enemy that
manages to get fushigoro in a bit of a
tight spot
he considers a worthy target for his
trump card and this fact highlights two
other dark traits of his quite well i
think the first is that he lacks
self-esteem
and is extremely insecure about his own
abilities
despite their clear power while both
gojo
and sukuna are confident of what megumi
is capable of
we're talking special great jiu jitsu
here megumi himself whenever he's
challenged
just tends to give himself up for the
sake of the rest
this makes him different from yuji while
yuji likes to sacrifice himself as a
last resort
after having thrown in everything he's
got megumi just
willingly gives himself up this is best
shown i think in the baseball match
against the kyoto students
the scenes where gojo comments on
itadore going for the home run
and megumi sacrificing himself for the
team are pretty straightforward
metaphors for their general mindset i
think
[Music]
and looking a bit deeper the second
thing that maego means kamikaze attempts
lay open
is that he has absolutely no sense of
self-worth
the underlying reason for this is of
course his childhoods
after he and his stepsister were
abandoned by their father and left as
orphans
it left a deep scar on his heart as a
result and
frankly quite understandably he
developed severe abandonment issues
making him very cautious about forming
new relationships
and yet once these relationships are
actually formed
he would do anything for the people he
holds dear
now gojo plays a very interesting role
here
while we know that he technically took
megumi in saving him from being sold to
the zanin family
it doesn't seem like he ever played a
real parental role for fushiguro
[Music]
the relationship between them is
definitely deeper than that of teacher
and student
but not deep enough to call it family at
least as far as we know right now
and as we can see from the small
flashback we get gojo
consistent with his persona is terrible
with people
and so he didn't really adopt megumi as
much as he scouted him as a potential
student
he helped him because he saw megumi's
potential to become a strong ally in the
future and his apparent lack of empathy
probably just enforced megomi's sense of
being worthless
which is tragic because gojo clearly
cares for megumi but was never able to
show it in a way that gave megumi any
sense of self-worth
instead gojo pushed him to get better
with the only thing
he knows strength
now interestingly enough this has
manifested in probably the best case
scenario for foshiguro instead of
hating and blaming everyone around him
for his terrible childhood like sasuke
or trying to prove himself or getting
attention from others
he has developed a truly selfless desire
to save and help those who in his
eyes deserve it even at the cost of his
own life
in an ironic twist while itadore tries
to be the
ultimate selfless person for selfish
reasons you can check out my analysis on
him for more on that
for shiguro due to his lack of
self-worth simply wants to be useful to
others
and thus actually is the truly
altruistic one of the two
this pretty unique dynamic becomes very
clear in his encounter with kamal during
the kyoto exchange event
here kamo claims that both of them are
the same
and this may actually be true both
dark-haired quiet introverts
both born outsiders to parents who were
rejected by their respective clans
and both inheriting their respective
clans highly prized jujutsu technique
earning them the attention of both the
zayn
and the camel family respectively
they're also both strategists who
try to act logical but ultimately tend
to be swayed by emotions instead
and both became jiu-jitsu sorcerers in
order to protect the people that they
most
care about megumi his sister and kamo
his mother
so why does megumi reject this statement
by kamos
so strictly after all the poor guy
simply wants to be understood
the real reason here is a moral one
giving us some more insights into
fushigoro's character
kamal basically argues that as members
of the big clans
they are expected to think in terms of
what is best for the family
and society as a whole thus there is no
room to view itadori from a human
perspective
sokuna is a threat and thus itadore as
his vessel
must be eliminated for the good of all
kamo uses this utilitarian argument and
his duty to his family
to justify a morally questionable
decision that he personally
does not agree with however to find
acceptance within the family and within
the g2 world
the rules must be obeyed for shigoro
however
despite also appearing to be someone
who's rational and who values rules
actually is a lot more like his teacher
gojo and evaluates issues based on his
personal impressions and gut feeling
we see this play out pretty nicely in
the very first two episodes
where megumi first cites the official
due to regulations that mandate him to
exercise itadorii
and yet he had already decided all along
based on his personal feelings that he
wanted to let him live
because he saw itadori as a good person
and yet while kamu's morality is clearly
faulty here
maegomiz is also based on a wrong
assumption
similar to gon in hansa hunter fushigoro
has a very simplified view of human
morality
dividing people into either good or bad
worth saving or
not worth saving all based on his
personal impression of them
itadori and his sister are good people
no matter what they do
the prisoner yuji wanted to save or all
the curses
bad guys and honestly it's not really
hard to see
why he would think that way having been
abandoned by both parents and unable to
help his sister giving her condition
megumi doesn't really know how to
survive in the world
but pretends that he does because no one
else will take care of him
and on top of that you can add the fact
that he was basically forced into
jiu-jitsu first by his dad
selling him and then by gojo intervening
just to ask him to come work with him
instead
and since he actually is an incredibly
kind and caring person at heart
this simplified way of looking at people
helps him protect himself from people
leaving him again
as a result fushigoro tells itadori that
he might end up saving people who will
kill someone in the future
the irony is that foshiguro has of
course done this as well
saving itadore has led to more death and
suffering
and the same might be true for other
people he deems to be good
in fact he and itadori have a quite
similar approach to the central moral
question of the story
what does it mean to live a good life
worth living for both
it's saving people however while yuji
thinks about this in terms of quantity
saving as many people as possible
fushigoro looks at it in terms of
quality who he thinks is worth saving
and yet despite this difference in
perspective and the apparent naruto
sasuke dynamic between them
the relationship between itadori and
foshigoro is not only a major twist on
the shonen troll but actually the most
positive aspect of the story
[Music]
megumi and yuji aren't rivals but
partners
they support each other and keep the
other from falling apart under their
respective darkness
and so despite their contrasting
personalities they are actually the
closest to each other and understand
each other the best
with the same fixation on saving people
in fact they've only ever had one
argument pretty much
right at the start of the story with the
different ideas on who to save
but then never again and even then they
respected each other's moral views
even if it contradicted their own
and so after itadori's death megumi
hands the prisoner's name tag to his
mother
to honor his friend's legacy as a result
both of them
push each other to grow without seeing
the other one as a threat
and in direct contrast to the sasukes
and bakugou's of the world
instead of refusing to acknowledge his
partner fushigoro always readily gives
validation to itadori
and defends him because protecting the
other is a major drive for both of them
they form a sort of yin and yang as they
complete each other and are pretty much
two sides of the same coin in a way
their relationship is represented really
nicely by fushigoro's black and white
wolves
just like yuji the white wolf dies
during the cursed womark
and yet its powers and strengths merge
with the black wolf
making him stronger overall and
similarly
yuji and megomi increasingly take on
traits from each other as the story
progresses
at the beginning is cold dispassionate
and entirely selective with his
sympathies
eugene contrast is warm friendly and
willing to sympathize with almost
anybody
and yet over time megumi takes on more
and more of yuji's emotional
confident and extroverted self
walitsadori gets a grip on his emotions
becomes more calculating and is actually
able to make harder decisions
and so in a world that has mostly
provided nothing but
pain and hardship for both of them they
make each other better
and stronger people
and this brings us all the way back to
the initial question
what happened between these two scenes
with the special curses
the answer is fushigoro has become a lot
more like itadori
and finally has the capability to not
only believe in himself
but also be more emotional and let those
emotions become a strength
very thematically fitting finally being
able to spit out his shadow
this unusual rival relationship is one
of the main reasons why jiu jitsu kaisen
works
and why it feels so unique and yet
familiar compared to other shonen
stories
another really important relationship is
that between yuji
and the sorcerer whose appeal is maybe
only topped by gojos
[Music]
and so i strongly suggest that you watch
nanami's video
right here thanks for watching peace